obvious the camera moves away because he
throws the ball but you can see just
enough of the blow to his leg and the
way the leg bends to know that it's a
serious knee injury
mri shows that he suffered as expected
to torn acl also a torn mcl and other
knee damage which means a delicate and
sensitive surgery a concern after
surgery for infection and i vividly
recall
when tom brady had his knee surgery in
2008 he had infection issues for much of
that year as he was recovering and also
the later end of the year that you
suffer that torn acl the more
challenging it is shireen to get ready
for the next year he surely won't be
involved in off-season workouts will he
be ready in time for training camp will
he be ready in time for the regular
season and meanwhile it's ryan finley
and brandon allen as the options for the
cincinnati bengals and not a lot of
other guys out there available and we
all have come to accept the reality that
no one is going to call colin kaepernick
because no one at this point would
choose having a more competitive
quarterback over making whatever
stupid-ass point the nfl's teams
continue to try to make all due respect
yeah they placed borough on injury
reserve this afternoon mike and they did
call up brandon allen so it's going to
be ryan finley and brandon allen and
they're not going to be very competitive
the rest of the way and you know joe
burrell frankly was one reason you
wanted to watch the bengals and i
thought they were a different team and
competitive despite their record i mean
i wanted to see what he was going to do
and how he was going to develop and they
were fun to watch uh with him at
quarterback and now the bengals have
turned back into the bengals the clock
has struck midnight
uh and and the slipper is off and this
is a team that i don't want to see much
the rest of the season i don't see much
of a reason to watch them and they're
going to end up with a high pick frankly
and and maybe in long term this helps
them but you know you worry about him as
you said mike the later in the season it
happens like carson wentz's happened
late in the season when he had his knee
injury and
you know who knows if that's affecting
him and the way he's playing now but it
it certainly took a while for him to get
back as opposed to tom brady who's
happened in week one and he was able to
get back but you know you want that
rookie quarterback to have an off season
and we don't know if it's going to be a
normal off-season or not we don't know
what the spring holds
but it would have been good for him to
get practice time with his receivers and
do things that you do in in an offseason
if they were able to do that next off
season and he's going to lose that
entirely for for whatever they're able
to do
and speaking of carson wentz another
carson who played for the bengals
caution palmer 2005 postseason first
throw of the game kimo von olhofen came
in low came in hot before it was a
penalty and it's that plant leg and i
recall in 2006 when carson palmer was in
the process of recovering one of the big
hurdles for him was mental because every
time you go to throw you have that left
leg out there exposed and you need to be
not and he and the quote was he was
seeing ghosts around his leg he was
worried about someone slamming into that
leg and again the rules are different
that doesn't give joe burrow a whole lot
of solace he's going to have to have a
big brace on that knee just to give him
some peace of mind and he's going to
have to develop that swagger that belief
you know he had that that
air of invincibility where i'm gonna go
do what i'm gonna do and i'm not worried
about getting hurt well that changes now
and there's a certain amount of it that
he needs to accept he needs to
understand he's vulnerable to potential
injury but at the same time he needs to
get to the point where he can
confidently step forward with that left
leg and throw the football or it's going
to affect his accuracy and his
development
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports